[Music]
my parents were from different worlds
and that was a product of the love that
never should have been get unite our
worlds one day
a son of the land and a son of disease
my mother always knew you were special
you are part of something deeper
you are the bridge between land and sea
your rightful place as king
[Music]
we're getting close now
oh yeah what's the what dying a thirst
there's no way Atlantis with this far
inland check this place out
[Music]
nothing of course it's not working it's
been sitting here collecting dust since
before the Sahar was a desert before the
Sahara was a desert let's see you do
your best thinking when you're not
thinking at all
all right now hold still hey what are
you doing we need water you know closest
source
[Music]
sure I could've just peed on it
in this Trident resides the power of
Atlantis
if you suck my power journey along the
edge of the world to the hidden sea
in the wrong hands
it would bring destruction
enhance the truhair
it would unite all our kingdoms above
and below
what should we've written it down first
I memorized it didn't you oh yeah what
did you say something something tried it
[Music]
the Beast has awakened
the time has come
for Atlantis to rise again
the hell are you
[Music]
[Music]
oh is awesome
coming to the surface
you are not going to win this
billions will die unless you help us
I'm no leader
not King
[Music]
and thanks miss always had a king
now I need something more
but what could be greater than again a
[Music]
hero
[Music]